part that's getting me is an evil spirit
from God boom yes so that's interesting
huh is Satan messing around with your
thoughts
find out on this episode of LED live
[Music]
exposing Darkness welcome to LED live
where we use the line of Christ to
expose the darkness in society to bring
out the truth and today we're going to
talk about feelings feelings it's going
to be a very interesting show but before
we do we want to thank all of our
patreons because we could not do this
without you and if you have any interest
in any of our shirts that we have go to
lightwear dot shop isn't that what it is
yeah
lightweird.shop so today's show is
fascinating because I found a a little
clip from Roger marnot you know what
Roger marneau is yes can I can I explain
what Roger is yeah so so Roger renau is
this this Christian that wasn't always a
Christian he was a member of the occult
at one time I mean this wasn't just some
occult the group that said we're gonna
worship Satan and in their basement
somewhere that they had no idea what was
going on this was a a a spirit
worshiping group of people that would
have a regular Spirits manifest them
ourselves and they knew the truth behind
this stuff they would these things would
manifest and tell them all of what is
actually going on like you know these
things are we are members uh we are
fallen angels we are uh worshiping
Lucifer you the members did I mean all
this stuff was really strange and uh he
was being groomed to be a part of this
society and so one of this what happened
was uh when he was at work one day
he was uh talking to his co-worker which
was a Christian and he said I had the
the truth in the Bible and he said give
me Bible studies I want to see what
you're all about gave them Bible studies
he became a Christian he says I know
exactly this is true Christianity
because this is what we talk about is so
dangerous to the luciferians that we're
worshiping and I remember the uh that
group he was not just like
just people from the street or something
like that were very important people
they were in that Society right yeah
they were they were like lawyers you
know like hoodie dark people a dark dark
you know hoods over with sunglasses and
everything they weren't you know creepy
people and this this was like you said
lawyers doctors people that were well
known in society and had high high
respect because they were um they they
had been given special privileges by the
luciferian
society not just the society itself but
by these fallen angels and so uh it was
it was very evident of what was going on
if you haven't read the story of Roger
marneau it's a fascinating book it's
called a trip into the supernatural
that's his testimony and it's also a
three and a half hour video on YouTube
If you rather watch that instead it's a
different books right I mean it's not
just one I mean it's different about
prayer
yeah yeah
um incredible answers to prayer he wrote
several of those because he started at
the end of his life a Prayer Ministry
where he would just pray for all the
people that would that would send him
letters and stuff like that amazing very
humble man at the very end of his life
unfortunately he's dead now but he does
he did have one last interview that I
found that was just fascinating and
here's a small clip from what it said
what he said at the end I'm going to put
the captions down at the bottom so you
can hear him better because the room is
kind of echoey but um it's you'll be
able to see the captions on the screen
check this out
when I was a spirit this
a high priest used to boast about
the great work that the angels of the
Great Master are able to do
and one thing that you'd love to talk
about is how angels can Flash piles and
images into people's minds and they came
with so precisely that the person
believes that those are their own
thoughts
can actually move upon people's
imagination the oblivity imagination
and then when the person's imagination
has been aroused to a certain extent
then they can play with their emotions
and mess up their lives okay that's it
right he said for instance they can't
create a field
in a person became create anger
create love
and packets they can actually forget
happiness in some persons and also they
can create grief and I remember it
saying you know
he says the spirit counselor was telling
me that they had a good time of
Christians because when there's there's
a if you know they see that the man died
and his wife has been nasty to him for
so many years and uh you know they're
with the dead and uh
an angel will move upon the Widow
lifestyles of pure mind and bring you
back people who remembers all the other
kindness that you did to her husband
even the little kindness and the bigger
ones
and down what they're doing here
they are leading you into a state of
breathing
that is out of ordinary and some people
have even taken their lives to be able
to escape Social Security
and I'm coming back from our question
again now
[Music]
we're living in a light of the enemy
it's not just it's not just about it or
right except God has to put up
but God has allowed
certain period of time
to the enemies of the Lord Jesus
to carry on
pair Wellness in this life
and he will not
you know go back on his a lot of time to
these people
fascinating what do you think about that
well I mean sometimes you had those
thoughts and you know sometimes you feel
like why I'm so down today
you know what I'm saying and sometimes
he what he was saying they
they mess around you
you feelings right but that later on
it's gonna be your emotions
so the emotions is like you're the
result of your feelings right because
you feel oh I feel this but now your
emotions your action
and
I had those kind of thoughts you know
sometimes like why why I'm so down today
you know I'm sure you guys you know if I
ask you guys hey you had that feeling
before yeah and
you know the Bible I mean
and debate and uh
David who's like singing music to
to solve because so it was tormented
with spirit
and I think we need to be
listen to a really good music to help us
out in those moments when the demons
they're talking to us you know sometimes
we don't realize that
maybe it's the enemy wow that's a really
powerful clip right there
do you think that these um
these uh all feelings are
the spirits messing with us
no
why
well I struggle with this topic in
general because like I'm like I always
struggle with
which thoughts are mine which thoughts
are the enemies which thoughts are gods
or which voices are mine their enemies
or Gods you know and
I don't know like and I for me like I
struggle with anxiety so I have thoughts
flying through my head all the time you
know but like I don't know how to tell
the difference especially like when
you've lived with it for so long you
don't really know I don't know yeah yeah
I agree and I don't think we need to
because I think the only answer to
either Spirits messing with us or to and
I agree with you and I'm just kind of
egg you're on why don't you agree with
that huh yeah yeah yeah yeah so uh I I
think the only answer is to pray the
only answer is God I mean regardless of
if it's in our own lives or if it is
external and these things are trying to
antagonize us the only thing we can do
is is rely on God and so I bring this
point up not because I'm trying to point
out anything specific but primarily I
want to I want to point out that this
world is not our own right we we don't
establish ourselves and say hey you know
what I'm gonna this is how it's going to
be we got to pray we got to ask God uh
for for help and everything we do
consecrate ourselves every single day to
the Lord because otherwise we're not
going to be able to
to uh to last to keep our emotions keep
our sanity right
um I think one thing too is I have
learned that God's voice is a God of
Peace
but then you know the devil can also
probably play on that I don't know
because he also said in this clip that
you can have feelings of happiness and
all these kind of things that was it
demons or Angels or whatever can Inspire
but
um I would think like let's say you do
have someone who died you know naturally
the human response is to be sad and to
grieve I think where it could be
dangerous is if like you have these
thoughts that are telling you like you
should go do a seance you know so that
you can awaken them they're not really
dead and I think when you start getting
all these suggestional things that you
don't know where that thought came from
it's not something that you would have
thought of on your own that's probably
where it can be dangerous
the Bible also says that's the spirit so
my question is how are you gonna test
them yeah so you need to
do it you need to test it with the word
I'm going to test it by accident I know
right I think we should we should we
should say you know if these Spirits are
saying or flashing things through our
minds or or
enforcing us to do a certain thing we
should test it with the spirit of God
with the word of God because the word of
God will tell us what's what's right and
wrong he's given us this for the last
days this the Bible basically the what
does the Bible say it's the um the two
testimonies the two tests the test the
what's the word I'm looking for
yeah the uh witnesses that has nothing
to do with testimonies but um yeah you
could Witness by sharing yourself
the two witnesses the New Testament in
the Old Testament but um what I think is
fascinating is that the this can happen
and the way it happens he said is by
flashing these memories through your
head you know God has given us the bible
to read and the reason we need to read
it I mean there's many reasons we need
to read it right but what I think brings
out he brings out a good point is that
Angels both good and bad are capable of
making us remember things so can you
imagine if we are memorizing scripture
if we are reading our Bible daily what
is the spirit of God what's the Holy
Spirit what's the angels that are
helping this the cause of God here doing
the same thing they're touching those
brain cells that help us remember those
good things that are found in the Bible
right yeah those promises the
when those the falling angels they give
you in those bad thoughts or something
like that I mean those promises that
you've been the good Angels they've been
helping you to memorize you know those
kind of it's gonna help you in that
difficult time can you think of any time
in your life when you were like oh man I
need to uh help someone or I need to uh
give a Bible verse to someone or maybe a
spur of the moment Bible study where you
were like
oh that reminds me uh let me tell you
about this I found in the Bible recently
we've all kind of had that at one time
if we can't think of any examples
immediately I mean there's always been
times at least in my life where I'm like
oh yeah I remember the Bible says right
there
Perhaps Perhaps that was a Divine moment
maybe we had
another being that was helping us over
our shoulder that was good
and so there's not necessarily just a
bad side to this topic there's also a
very good one but do we have anywhere in
the Bible and I think you alluded to it
Alex
can we prove this
from the Bible because that's our our
like you said test the spirits if
something someone's saying this and it's
like whoa whoa whoa where do we find
that in the Bible that's our main
question we should ask right
is there any place in the Bible that
says yeah the uh the the spirits can
touch our brain and tell us uh flash
memories through our brain so that they
can change our our thought processes
there is one I know I wish I had my
phone so I could really look this up but
there was one that was saying that the
holy spirit is our Helper and it'll help
us to remember yes I don't remember
where that's from though yes like the
exact
is anyone
and also the New Testament
and uh I I think that's a excellent one
I didn't put that one in that's that's a
really good point and I think I should
have brought that one out I should have
consulted everyone before I did this
study but um I'm still at it yeah yeah
we can still add it I was actually
um uh talking to Candy I'm gonna call
her out here she's not here she's did a
wonderful job she found me a Bible verse
that actually explains this and um I
didn't even think of it so first Samuel
18 6-11 says now it happened as they
were coming when David returned from
killing the Philistines that the women
came out of all the cities of Israel
singing and dancing to meet Saul with
tambourines with joy and with other
musical instruments the woman saying as
they played and said Saul has slain his
thousands and David his ten thousand so
I can't imagine that's gonna make Paul
not very happy but uh let me Saul Saul
not very happy
then Saul became very angry for his
lyrics this lyric displeased him and
said they have given David credit for
ten thousand but to me they have given
credit for only thousands now what more
can he have but to about the kingdom and
Saul I David with suspicion from that
day on so this sets up the the whole
idea first of all the backstory so you
can kind of see what what is literally
going on here but listen to what happens
next
hey Brittany can you read the the second
part for me
now it came about on the next day that
an evil spirit from God rushed upon Saul
and he raved in the midst of the house
while David was playing the harp with
his hand as usual and a sphere was in
Saul's hand then Saul hurled the spear
for he thought I will pin David to the
wall but David escaped from his presence
twice
okay so what actually happened there
Saul became very angry why
he became very angry number one he had
this thing that happened to him before
but number two jealousy jealousy evil
spirit came in and said oh remember that
boink and now he's like I'm so mad at
him I'm going to pin him against the
wall I mean when you pin someone against
the wall with a spear I don't think they
they are are just trying to you know
play pin the tail on the donkey here
they're not trying to uh you know just
get his clothes stuck to the wall we're
not duct taping someone to the wall
because they want to be stuck there
right he was trying to kill David
so so what
the part that's getting me is an evil
spirit from God boom yes so that's
interesting huh so when it says an evil
spirit from God a lot of times the Old
Testament hasn't extrapolated the idea
of Satan yet and so since all things
were created by God it said an evil
spirit of God or anything from God it
doesn't necessarily mean that God made
them evil but he did allow this to
happen because everything that bad
happens has to be approved for the great
controversy between Good and Evil
and that way it was essentially from the
courts of God saying yeah okay I'll let
you do this knowing that David was going
to get away so why didn't people have
that Concept in mind it was it was a
it's interesting huh because not
everything is revealed in the Bible even
Paul says in the New Testament we see
through a glass Darkly there's some
things that even now today we don't have
a completely revealed but
we uh those are some excellent questions
and I I think that um
I think it's an interesting uh
interesting thought but um there's
another part in the Bible where it goes
in even further and lots of theology
students have dug into this and wondered
about this but that's essentially the
answer do you kind of understand what
what what what's going on
kind of though kind of
the short of it is the main point is
that
um
is that these entities can
make you feel different things at
different times
yeah yeah but okay so let's say we are
born into sin
so we naturally now have feelings of
anger and jealousy
I think sometimes
and this is just me thinking right I
could be wrong but I think sometimes
we can blame
the spiritual realm for a lot of things
of our existence and not take into
account what was our own actions and
thoughts versus the spiritual one so
it's like I guess what I'm asking is how
much of the spiritual realm is involved
in our existence can we really not do
anything absolutely on our own we're
just puppets in this whole thing
yeah I think that's my question it's
like multiple layers going on right now
but I'll stop there for now
so so the Bible says we wrestle not
against flesh and blood but the powers
and principalities of darkness and and
you're 100 right how can we know
I don't think we can
I mean unless you guys disagree I don't
think we can we I mean we don't have the
the tools the instruments the senses to
say oh yeah that was a naval spirit I
mean that would take away from from the
delusion and the what they call the it's
a deception right
um and that's what Satan has over us
he's a more powerful and Powerful being
because of that he can he lives longer
he is more powerful and he can uh for
the most part manipulate us
but the good news is that Christ came to
die for us so he can't just do whatever
he wants to our brain and because of
that
he is withheld and and uh and and God
says you know what you can we're going
to continue this conversation about what
you believe can be done with my my
creation until you are proven wrong and
at that point
the world is over we're done and we are
the Righteous or will be in heaven uh I
have a question I don't know if it's in
this specific moment
but I believe
and I think in the Bible said that
the devil does cannot read our minds
you know as different that he putting
ideas
maybe because how we act or maybe the
he sees this Old Situation you know and
younger because of my mom my dad or at
work or whatever driving the freeway or
something and then he's like okay I'm
gonna
you know give you these kind of thoughts
you know be angry to that person or
something but it's different like that
he knows our thoughts God knows our
thoughts God knows our thoughts but I
don't I don't think so the enemy yeah no
all of that so I don't know that
also kind of like help us
um a lot right yeah I mean uh let me I'm
glad that God knows our thoughts you
know because he's there to help us out
like hey son hey daughter what what are
you doing you know let the holy spirit
to guide you in all truth
yeah it's interesting I can't find
anything in the Bible that says that
Satan can read our thoughts it's only
god that actually knows the I mean God
it says in the Bible God knows our the
thoughts of of man mankind so both men
and women and so it's interesting it's
interesting that God knows our thoughts
he knows what we're thinking but um
Satan you know he's a creative being he
doesn't know this stuff they don't have
the senses to know that stuff they don't
know how the technology or whatever they
need to do this well now they do that I
mean I just think of like when you have
social media and like all day everyday
people are just like updating Twitter or
like I just went to the bathroom or just
stupid things like that like now it's
like especially when you have algorithms
and you see the science behind like or
when you go on Google like it can just
predict what your next thought is and I
think just those repetitive things just
kind of gets you thinking oh like I kind
of know where this person's thought
patterns are but maybe the exact thought
no he doesn't right so that's that's
really interesting it's a great point
because they they uh
I'm sure just by being able to I guess
use the computer terms right to your
brain but not read from it you can um
you can instruct something and say hey
remember that hey you need to tell
someone about that remember that time
you told someone when you had this heart
emotion yeah you need to go tell someone
about that and then you spill the beans
about everything you're talking about to
your friend or your relative or or your
co-worker and now now Satan knows your
thoughts I mean how manipulative is that
right and now he knows everything you're
thinking and how often do we give away
our our most secretive
um uh Treasures that that would be used
by Satan later to manipulate us just by
going and gossiping or going and and
telling someone that that uh necessarily
may or may not need to know it's not
Facebook has a little
uh sentence that says what are you
thinking oh yeah right yeah what's on
your mind today what's on your mind do
you really want to tell you they're
going to block me
everything that's on your mind yeah put
it on Facebook it's the world to see so
you had a question like do you own your
own thoughts right or something like
that so
what other avenues the enemy mess around
with their mind
um
oh I have a question
music
do you know how it was Form music
with two elements
what words and music and
emotions feelings feelings right yeah
she got it right wow so as words and
feelings so that's what you have this
music of you know romantic music you
know and rock and you know all these
engagement so your emotions like like
that so what are you angry you're not
going to put some piano thing I mean you
want something
you were excited you want to put
something like you know happy or
something
well like let's say you hear the Disney
follow your heart stuff then you listen
to certain types of music it's like how
involved does the devil need to be at
that point if he's already
rewired your brain to think a certain
way
so when you're listening for like from a
young age you hear you know Disney's
messages follow your heart and then you
listen to different types of music and
they're already putting thoughts in your
mind you know it's already changing the
way that you're thinking how involved
does you know the devil need to be in
our lives to get us to think that way if
he's really been
I guess I hate to say it this week so it
gives him a lot of credit but like
training us to think a certain way you
know because like the Bible does say
that we need to re
um to not conform to pens of the world
of this world renew our our minds our
thoughts and and we have to put an
effort to think about things that are
lovely and pure and beautiful so
yeah I just
how involved
how involved is it you have to be like
it's not like he's just there Whispering
thoughts in our mind all the time you
know or is he through music and all
these other things well that's the thing
that's the thing he's adding these
little cues in your brain but on the
other side so is the good angels and
there's twice as many good angels as
there are bad Angels right so so we have
twice the amount of of help that as we
do with the the Demonic realm and so
they are there for every bad thing
that's going in your head two more good
things hopefully are also going into
your head and so we have that balance
that we can choose good or we can choose
evil and I think you hit the nail and
head earlier when you said that we were
born and we have these Tendencies
towards uh our our uh doing evil but we
can through the grace of God correct
those not us doing it but also that it
is um it is uh Christ working in us that
causes that to happen
I have a question go for it so you said
that um
Satan can't read our thoughts right and
so like sometimes he creates Avenues so
that we tell people our thoughts and
spill the opinions on things so that he
can use it against us in the future
like what about like when you're
depressed like you go to counseling and
you tell your counselor or all your
thoughts and things like that so it's
not healthy for you to keep your
thoughts to yourself but at the same
time it's like if you say it out loud
Satan can use it against you
and I I think that Satan has a a good uh
psychology on everybody I mean after
studying uh Humanity for 6 000 years he
he kind of has it figured out if the if
you make a kind of a Grimace face then
you probably don't like that I mean he
probably has it down to the nanometer
right he knows when you'd like and
dislike something but so we just really
got a rely on God I mean we just we just
really gotta um rely on him for our our
purposes here on Earth concentrate
ourselves every morning because that's
the only way we can get through this
right it's a it's a war and we are in
the middle of it and we can't do
anything about it but pray
I don't think Satan himself knows
because he's not omnipresent right but I
did want to throw that in there because
I don't want because at that point
um
I know a lot of times what I struggle
with is putting like Satan is the
opposite of God and that's not true like
God has no opposite right because Satan
is an angel he's just the opposite of a
good Angel right and so I think just
removing that omnipresence and power
from him really just kind of I guess
rebalances things in my life but
whatever demon like I'm like we have
like probably
you know like demons around but Satan
himself he doesn't have that much power
yeah no they're not omnipresent they're
not omniscient they don't know
everything right and how do they get
tired too
they definitely make mistakes I was I
would bring this up the other day the
Bible
they're singing hymns all the time one
thing I I was thinking about was do
angels make mistakes well obviously
because this whole sin thing was a
mistake right that was their error and
so they thought oh I can be like God I
can I don't need a moral authority over
me and so now they're in this huge
predicament where they're gonna
completely lose their life over this and
uh at the end of time when they realize
that God's people are going to be taken
up there they're going to be just mad
because they they they they really
messed up on some people they wanted to
make the rest of his group of people a
part of their team and they couldn't it
was their mistake and so these things
are not perfect they are not they're not
good and we have a lot of a lot of power
in God a lot more than anything else
that is is against us I think the Bible
verse says if God can be for us then who
can be against us right amen I found one
other example I think is
just very interesting it's in um uh it's
of an LED or an LED light that we did
recently
um and it's uh that Satan is priest
remember this the Satanist priest that
became
a quote-unquote Christian that has been
debunked he actually didn't see Jesus
but he was seeing a manifestation of the
devil that pretending to be Jesus to
give him
bad things that were not correct in the
Bible and if you haven't seen that
episode you should go back and watch
that on on
on our Channel Little Light Studios so
check it out but um this is a short clip
just a short clip of of him talking
about his feelings and what happened
during that experience when he saw this
manifestation of uh of what he thought
was Jesus but was actually a demon you
ready
and I had to do a ritual by myself to
see
what is the next step how do I get more
more power more influence
and I did this Rachel and
I opened myself up
and Jesus appeared and I was extremely
cocky
and I said whatever
if you are Jesus
you need to prove it
and he flooded me
was the most beautiful love and energy
that's how I recognized the love of
Christ
so he recognized the love of Christ
through the love and energy that he felt
when this being came to him
and made him feel this way
made him feel
lucky he said that
um the way he knows that it's Jesus is
because he's flooded with love right and
from the first video that you showed us
like the Roger mourno he said that this
evil angels can flesh feelings and
thoughts and they can even flesh love
so it's like how many people today are
in the wrong religion but think that oh
I'm in the right religion because I feel
so much love and peace and everything is
perfect oh man wow girl preach it that's
really good that's a wrap okay
I've heard the term I feel so blessed
here so many times right and you wonder
do they is this is this how you know
that you were in the right place I think
it's part of it wow like I think that
following God with all of our heart mind
soul and you know of course I think I
think sentiment is a part of it like God
has feelings you know but yeah that's
that's where it gets tricky right
because we can use our feelings as a
more like I feel like this is the right
decision you know wow wow and we have
instincts that God gave us so like I
feel like something is wrong here you
know so feelings do play a part I guess
it's just really learning
when to
I don't know like that God is
he should come before all of that you
know like it has to be connected both
heart and mind he has to make sense you
know being another religions in
different you know in other parts of the
world and they
preaching you to say hey you will find
you know inner peace
and you're gonna be blessed you got lots
of money and all this stuff so when
people that come to Christianity
and it's wonderful right because they
they feel the the Forgiveness right they
feel that guilt and you know like no
more guilt and everything the the love
of God and everything yes
but the thing is that the the Christian
Life
if you read
and the gospels and in the whole Bible
there
upside Downs and it's not everything is
going to be in a nice nice beautiful
colors you know in your life I mean
you're gonna go through things and the
powerful thing is that we cannot go
through things by ourselves
is through Christ that we can do all
things through him so and there are
religions like you know you know hey
you're going to be in the top of the
mountain and enjoy breeding and that's
the wonderful thing yes it is wonderful
thing you will find the true God there
but it's difficult to go through it yeah
but it's not in our own strength yes
with with through God Jesus so so I
think it's interesting because right now
we're in the midst I think in our
generation of a redefining of the word
love
and and where love as defined in the
Bible is the duty that someone has been
given to do something for someone else
it is doing something for others but is
a duty that is instilled in us right so
just as a perfect example would be uh
Christ in Gethsemane he went there to
cry his heart out before God please take
this cup from me not me but uh but your
will be done in my life this was true
love love that wanted to have a our uh
Us in heaven but he didn't necessarily
have the gushy emotional feelings that
uh one that was going to get him there
right he wanted it done and so uh
In Our Lifetime Love the word love is
becoming a a weak sentimentalism right
it's it's like this oh I remember that I
wish I had that type of love I remember
when we were all in love you know it's
not it's not a commitment it's not a
focused it's not and I'm not just
talking about this in the marriage sense
or in the relationship sense I'm talking
about this you know what we have a duty
to do something for someone for at work
at home for family members and for our
spouses and for our boyfriends and
girlfriends and that is the duty that is
true love
and so when we uh we hear these things
on the radio on TV all the time and it
says it says oh I went down and I I I
found love well no you found lust dude
you found you found uh that gushy
feeling you know and it causes us to
think about this idea of Love totally
different I was gonna say you can't read
and find love without redefining God
because God is love and so I also see
that there is redefining Jesus in our
culture as well
and I think it ties along with this
whole sentimentalism love type of thing
because I was reading recently Isaiah 53
and that chapter really convicted me
because I was like
you know Jesus was here on Earth what I
have followed him because a lot of
people he was rejected he became a man
of sorrow people hated him you know like
they really did not like him at all and
you know there were times they tried to
throw him off the cliff I mean all these
different things that and they rejected
him and he went and died on the cross
alone like even Peter who was closest to
him
denied him three times you know so it's
like Jesus is not this like yes he is
love but he also has
um
this personality I guess this truth that
will convict you of sin like you just
you can't stay the way you are and come
to Jesus it just doesn't work that way
you know like you're either going to
become like him or stay as you are and I
think sometimes to protect ourselves we
make Jesus like ourselves and then it's
like we really miss out on experiencing
that transformation that he's trying to
give us because we want him to be like
us and we don't want to change and I
think reading Isaiah 53 really just
I don't know it just really changed
everything
for me you know because it's like you
see all these preachers sitting out
there with like all these nice cars and
Jesus was poor you know like I mean even
the the priests who had all the biblical
knowledge didn't even recognize Jesus
when he came and they wanted to kill him
so I think just when you see things like
this I mean look at the poster he has in
the back I mean think you can't see
Jesus and and leave that and think
that's okay because that's not of God
you know so anyway that was a mouthful
that's true because Jesus is the light
yeah so it cannot be Darkness there and
what you were saying that is very
powerful that if you want to come to
Jesus I mean you are going to be
transformed because he is the
he is
I mean he's the person of transforming
people's lives yeah if you're thinking
that you're gonna be coming as you are
yeah he wants you but he is the person
he's gonna be transforming you right
that you thoughts is not your thoughts
anymore
you know your action's gonna be there
and it's
you know each day you know like you were
saying like hey we need to
every morning and say Here I Am Lord you
know help me in those areas you know and
and he's going to do it yeah yeah that's
true there is that surrendering to him
that is also I think somewhat lost in
our culture it's very much how can I
make God work for me you know so I think
that Serenity like you were saying Jesus
surrendered himself in Gethsemane like
that wasn't uh you know these people
don't even care about me you know like
it's it's whatever I'm not gonna die for
them and he had all the power to you
know raise himself but
am I wrong about that no yeah he he was
God I mean he he had said hey you know
what I have surrendered my any any power
that would selfishly you know for myself
I don't have any more here on Earth and
I would use my power by you know relying
on God just as we all can and um and and
he he did stuff for other people though
yeah yeah and so it was just that
surrendering constantly it's not about
me it's about somebody else
you know and just denying himself of all
the luxuries that he could have had on
Earth you know so that we can be where
we are today having the knowledge of him
having hope for the future and things
like that so thank you again for joining
us today thank you to our patreons for
helping us out because without you we
can't do this and we look forward to
seeing you again next week
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
based media Ministry with a passion for
today's youth by God's grace our videos
has been circulating YouTube and
reaching thousands of people I mean
seriously thousands of people as the
popularity of our videos began to rise
we realize a problem what about the
countries that only speak English we
heard your requests and having an answer
by creating new life Studios
International this YouTube channel is
assigned to be a hub for people to enjoy
little life Studios Production and their
own native tongue a big thank you to all
the volunteers who have helped us with
translation voiceovers and editing we
encourage you to utilize this Source by
subscribing and sharing our videos with
your friends and family
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign